I had a Sona question I'm I know that
I'm coming in with questions and that's
awkward love I'm holding up a little
note card I'm loving this so far this is
delightful my Sona question is with
Conan you go so hard on him what is too
far have you ever said something that's
too
mean and then it's like what like like
we got to cut that out it's too mean I
don't think we've I I have to say you
guys could tell me I don't think we've
ever cut out
anything that you guys when you guys go
after me I don't think we've ever cut
out anything we've never cut out
anything when you don't act like you
don't come after us oh yeah there's no
limit There's No Limit my record is
clear it's all in the history books do
you know what I mean there's no it's
there's like it's like World War II
footage we've all seen it yes I go it's
like world there's no limit it's not
like World War II footage it is yeah
it's you've completely misunderstood
World War II really and footage I
thought World War II was a lot of
passive aggressive bickering between
Stalin Hitler and Churchill my God Conan
how did you miss this you read history
wasn't it a feud between
podcasts well and now I have to go back
and look at these again back then it was
radio it was passive aggression between
radio hosts yeah Orson Wales was
involved yeah I don't know I don't know
to answer your question well Sona I mean
Matt you would know because you I don't
think I have ever cut anything you've
said to him I think I've cut one or two
exchanges with you and me and not
because they were like uh bad it was
more like they just for whatever reason
took the air out or didn't land or
something like that right that would be
your fault it would have been if if
anything there have been moments where I
was like I should have gotten gone
harder on you there's more I should have
said the one I was listening to the
other day I admire this I I do ads in my
podcast I have to say what's in the ad I
I don't know what the hell you guys are
doing I know like you doing an ad for
like Conan TV or something and at the
end of it Sona had made fun of it so
much I was like does this even
exist we did an add like no one wants to
watch that Conan you know what we did we
did an ad oh my God we did an ad the
other day Mike this is true we did an ad
the other day and it's you know I read
the sometimes I'm reading these cold and
we get
they slide this piece of paper in front
of me like what's this one and I just
start going and I say like you know if
you want to monitor your your cats if
you want to monitor your your cat's
Health this device uses lasers and
ultralight sound to measure the quantity
quality and size of your cat's poops
basically and then gives you upto-date
analysis of what your cat's Health could
be in the future and then I went on a
long rant about the fall of Western
Civilization yeah fair enough I don't
know on this show where the ads begin or
end no and I've always
thought well what has been advertised
you know I don't know what the call the
action is my my ads my ads are a dare to
advertise on conter B need a friend it's
like if you can handle this advertise I
think what's happening is rival
companies are paying for the other
company's ads so that you will do damage
to their business yes it's an enemy it's
an enemy move smart move it's like World
War II in
it is just like in World War II he
learned it from World War II tactics
when Churchill paid for ads that were
pushing what Hitler wanted it's
propaganda it's operation mince meat
yeah it is so funny the idea of of
Toyota desperately plotting to have me
do a Ford
ad they know oh this will get them this
will really Ford it's like what
they wanted was thir seconds of of an
advertisement and what they get is 5
minutes of
[Laughter]
nothing